let's take a look at ncbi's newly
enhanced genome data viewer you can now
view and analyze more than 500
eukaryotic reference sequence or refseq
genomes take the next two minutes to
discover the GD bees versatility on the
viewers home page you may find your
organism of interest or use a common or
scientific name to quickly search for an
organism or explore what other organisms
are available you can begin your
analysis of a particular assembly
by entering a gene a location of
phenotype or even an ncbi accession
number
once in the viewer you have all of the
features of the sequence viewer
including numerous zoom controls
and extensive track configuration where
you can load predefined sets of tracks
either ncbi recommended track sets for
specific topics or save and manage your
own sets of tracks within your my NCBI
account there is also a configuration
menu for choosing among hundreds of
tracks that we provide including
expression tracks of RNA seek data and
many new variation tracks and don't
forget that you can upload your own data
either here or use the your data widget
on the left to add a track of a line
data from a file on your local machine
or at a URL
your new track appears in the sequence
viewer allowing you to compare with the
wealth of NCBI tracks we also recently
added a blast function allowing you to
see recent blast alignments in the
viewer that was just a sampling of the
genome data viewers capabilities look
for links to the gdv on many ncbi record
pages including assembly
genome
Geo
Jean
and coming soon to blast
you